welcome to the exciting world of cyber
security imagine a digital real where
Brave companies are guardians of Online
safety these companies have the most
excellent tools and tricks to protect us
from sneaky hackers and all sorts of
digital buddies in this video we'll
introduce you to the top 10 superheroes
of the cyber security World these
companies are like the Avengers of the
internet but instead of capes they were
the lines of code they have got high
tech gadgets super smart experts and a
mission to keep a digital world safe
we'll introduce a few organizations that
stand in Paramount in the fight against
digital threats with their Best in Class
teams and a few more stay ahead to
Shield the confidential information
through their robbers tactics let me
share some fascinating statistics with
you that illustrate the impact and
potential of cyber security before we
delve into the fascinating cyber world
according to glasdow the average salary
of a cyber security engineer is hundred
and thirty thousand dollars in the
United States and rupees 7 lakh per
annum in India so get ready to meet the
Cyber Shield wielding Champions who are
stopping the hackers in their tracks and
making sure your online world is as safe
as it can it's time to dive into the
world of cyber security superheroes so
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
today we bring you the list of the exact
top 10 organizations that are the Titans
of the cyber security World in 2024 .
before we get started if these are the
type of videos you would like to watch
then hit that subscribe button and the
bell icon to get notified whenever we
drop a new video this postgraduate
program in cyber security will help you
learn comprehensive approaches to
protecting your infrastructure and
securing data including risk analysis
mitigation and compliance you will get
foundational to Advanced skills through
industry-leading cyber security
certification courses in this program
for admission to this postgraduate
program in cyber security candidates
should have a bachelor's degree with an
average of 50 or higher marks
candidates may have a non-programming
background and candidates with one plus
year of work experience are preferred
for this program
so join now seats are filling fast the
course link is mentioned in the
description box below so without any
further delay let's hand over this
session to our training expert so these
are the top 10 cyber security companies
for 2024.
so moving forward we will see these
companies about these companies one by
one Palo Alto Network 40net crowdstrike
McCafe OCTA IBM our Cisco Microsoft
Services checkpoint
so moving forward let's start with Palo
Alto Network
founded in 2005 Palo Alto network is a
leading Global cyber security company
with over 54 000 customers in
approximately 150 countries their
platform automated security tasks using
analytics simplifying protection for the
users data and application
they offer cyber security solution to
various Industries like Manufacturing
Finance retail Healthcare and oil and
gas and many more other covering Network
cloud and mobile devices in private SAS
and public Cloud environment Palo Alto
Network provides Advanced firewall
endpoint protection Cloud security
threat detection and prevention notably
their cloud-based security products and
advanced firewalls are trusted by over
85 Fortune 100 companies and 63 percent
of the global 2000. moving forward next
we let's see the 40 net 49 network
security provider is not averse to
rigorous testing earning its placement
on second of our format list for cyber
security software and Hardware despite
achieving sales exceeding 4 billion
cyber analysts anticipate a robust 35
percent of annual growth rate over next
five years
48 Excellence core network security
domain and Exhibits significant progress
in other critical security areas like
Siem and EDR tynet has leveraged its
networking expertise to assume
leadership roles in related markets such
as sdwan software-defined wide area
network the companies enjoy High
customer satisfaction ratings
particularly in aspect like product
capabilities value ease of use and
support which have enabled it to
penetrate a small business Market as
well any list have also commented 14 net
frequently featuring an alongside Palo
Alto and other in prominent posting in
Gartner magic quadrants and Forester
wave reports going forward let's see
crowdstrike
the cloud strike Falcon presents an
integrated platform that effectively
tackles critical security issues such as
threat intelligence ID security and
Cloud protection moreover it comes fully
equipped with extended detection and
response xdr capabilities to provide
comprehensive defense against threat
through xdr crowdstrike has the
capability to gather and analyze
crowdstrike has the capability to gather
and analyze data across networks Cloud
environments and various platforms
enabling a deep understanding of thread
levels and the early detection of
anomalies before they result in
irreversible harm
so next on the list is Avast founded in
1988 hours has gained prominence as a
notable provider of cyber security
solution the company boasts a growing
patent portfolio and compassing location
Technologies machine learning artificial
intelligence malware detection and
prevention and iot Internet of Things
Technologies I must also take pride in
its extensive range of threat protection
product design for the businesses
including its highly sought after Cloud
care solution
it's worth nothing that cloud care
solution offers both Network and
endpoint security
while Avast offers free antivirus
software it's essential to remark that
it may not affect all the types of
malware the free version of provides
essential real-time protection which
proves valuable especially if you have a
family members who tend to click on
every download now
so moving forward let's see McAfee
McAfee with its effective security
solution offers production against
potential risk these Services
encompasses all aspect of your company
asset including mobile devices and
substational crowds resources
for instance my Cafe has establied a
partnership with the prominent
technology solution provided Xerox to
address the security concern of their
customer through this collaboration the
technology giant has introduced connect
key technology and tendon with McAfee to
ensure secure data transmission to and
from their cities this inscription
capabilities empowers users to
concentrate on innovating their products
without the burden of security breach
concern
aims to break away from the conventional
Network Premier security model and
instead provides integrated solution for
countering threats across various
platforms
with OCTA support you can effectively
oversee potential threats while
safeguarding both your organization on
premises networks and Cloud
infrastructure OCTA employs a
programmatic approach to deliver
automated response to threats when
combined with addictive multi-factor
authentication this platform establish a
robust layer of security around all your
assets
so next on the list is checkpoint
checkpoint provides a distinctive
approach to cyber security solution
through a multi-tired architecture known
as Infinity designed to bolster
production additionally it is equipped
with Advanced GN V threat prevention
capabilities to safeguard data within
the cloud and on remote devices such as
mobiles what sets organization apart its
dedicated intelligence complemented by
an incident response team that specify
in data-driven services with features
like thread hunting and tabletop
exercises it ensure comprehensive
protection for all interconnected
systems so next on the list is Cisco
Cisco stand out as one of the rapidly
expanding cyber security solution
providers in the market the company
distinguishes itself through its
adaptable offering highlighted by the
feature known as secure remote work
these components render this package
ideally suited for evolving landscape of
remote work models
so number one is global access to WebEx
meetings and messaging second is
distance identity verification for user
devices and application the third is
robust umbrella security to combat a
wide area of threats the fourth one is
email security measures to eradicate
malware and Virus Infection Cisco also
delivers continuous updates and
leverages threat intelligence to
streamline the security process you can
invest in versatile solution like Cloud
endpoint and firewall security
so next on the list is Microsoft
Services another prominent entry on The
Roaster is Microsoft a technology giant
headquartered in Washington Microsoft is
dedicated to providing cyber security
solution that align with your strategic
goals much like IBM it employs a
structured approach to identify and
mitigate risk this methodology
encompasses stages such as first one is
evaluating the risk level the second is
conducting a dynamic identify framework
assessment the third is implementing
measures to secure against lateral
account movement the fourth one is
ensuring rapid response and Recovery in
the event of incidents businesses have
warmly embraced this brand considering
Microsoft claim of surpassing the 10
billion threshold in Security Services
Revenue alone in just one year the
security industry experience remarkable
40 crore
so next on the list is IBM cyber
security services IBM a technology
leading companies offering a
comprehensive area of cyber security
services tailored to your company's
requirement
the organization asserts its capability
to assess a mitigate risk through the
four distincts method the first one is
identification in this phase the
objective is to diverse a strategy for
managing and reducing risk that impact
critical element like people data and
system the second one is protection
emphasizing digital transformation IBM
45 every corporate asset and reduce
resources through a zero trust approach
the third one is detection the
Enterprise leverages artificial
intelligence to proactively respond to
emerging risks and assesses potential
threats based on historical data the
fourth one is response to expedite the
response time and minimize system risk
IBM offers Around the Clock incident
response Services these are the cyber
security companies
to which you can apply for the cyber
security jobs being cyber security
analyst cyber security engineer risk
analyst and enjoy the handsome package
or salary
with that we have come to end of this
video on the top 10 companies for cyber
security for 2024. if you have any
question or doubt related to this video
please comment below thank you for
watching till then stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign